this guy's not a light guy he he's he's
a guy that some people are in the middle
are careful on what to say about him
because they know they need him some
people are very careful to see if you
push too much he may over regulate you
he may take because he's got a lot of
power he's like okay this guy's a very
powerful person yeah you brought up
drone Powers bigger than power no he's
not big I don't know if he's big no he's
not bigger than power Powell maybe
shamat says Powell may be the most
powerful man uh because he controls Wars
if the interest rates go high you can't
finance a war but what are your thoughts
about what he's doing with ripple the
Ripple Army I had John D eaten here the
lawyer representing Ripple what are your
thoughts about what's going on with
ripple and how he is handling the Ripple
case Ripples and unregistered security
it's pretty obvious there's a company
the company owns a bunch of it they sell
it to the general public but there's no
they never took the company public
there's no disclosures
right so so the sec's position is you're
selling an unregistered security it's a
it's a crypto token right just like
ethereum it's a non-registered security
it's controlled by a few people in the
ethereum foundation and consensus
ftt just like Salon perfect but here's a
follow-up unregistered security here's a
follow-up on that I don't own a single
Ripple just so we know so full
disclaimer I'm not a ripple guy but if
if both of them are unregistered why
Target Ripple and not Target ethereum
the way he is targeting Ripple
and by the way this is coming from a guy
that owns uh ethereum not Ripple yeah I
think I think the best thing for the
world would be with the if the SEC
pretty much shut down all of it
it's all unethical right I mean the
Bitcoin position would be
Bitcoin is an ethical commodity all of
these other altcoins are unregistered
Securities they're all just Equity
tokens issued by a company in order to
get around going public and they're
committing Securities fraud ethereum
included of course especially ethereum
you know ethereum's got 20 billion
dollars of each token locked up in the
staking contract right now and there's a
couple of people that may or may not
give it back to you ever
now that isn't that the definition of
investment contract if if a bank took 20
billion dollars of your assets froze the
the window and said you can't have your
money back ever it may be in the year
2024 we're not sure we're just going to
keep it we may actually give you
interest on it we may take it all we may
you know we may slash it
that's the definition of a security
right it's an investment of money in a
common Enterprise you know relying upon
the efforts of others an expectation of
profit
the whole the whole point is if you want
a crypto asset to be a commodity you
can't rely upon four Engineers a company
a CEO if if a person can make a decision
it's not a commodity anymore the fact is
Ripple's got a company ethereum's got a
company ethereum Foundation has
Engineers you're literally waiting on
the engineers that work for the ethereum
foundation to write the code to give you
your money back and then you're also
waiting to find out what the monetary
policy will be they change it half a
dozen times in the last six years it's
always changing to you it's xrp and
ripple the same thing
there are both on registered securities
xrp and yeah xrp is just the equity
token of Ripple
yeah
so I mean it seems quite obvious right
if you wanna if you want a road map for
how you create a commodity you have to
do it the way Satoshi did it you create
a protocol
you give it to the world you disclaim
beneficial ownership of it you disclaim
control of it and you disappear
that's what Satoshi did it was a gift to
the world if the founder is still around
and the founder is a billionaire and the
founder is spending hundreds of millions
or billions of dollars to defend the
token isn't it obvious that it's a
software company with an equity
so I I think that that's pretty evident
with all these crypto tokens what you
have is you have
the complete sham Ponzi schemes you know
like the collapse in a hurry like Terra
Luna then you have crypto tokens that
are unregistered Securities that are
perhaps somewhat pseudo-competently
managed that don't collapse but they're
still unregistered Securities which
makes them unethical to promote
and then you have crypto currencies like
tether and circle they attempt to have
backing right Circle purports have a
hundred percent backing uh for their
coin we know that to like 83 percent of
tether deposits are backed by U.S
treasuries if you're to believe their
attestations
but again those
those are not publicly traded companies
so I think the one thing that's missing
in the crypto industry is by and large
nearly everybody in the crypto Market
has never taken a company public they
don't understand Security's law they're
like if you're going to be kind you're
going to say they're well-meaning
technologists that are enthusiastically
pursuing new ideas
but generally they're pursuing new ideas
and an irresponsible era inappropriate
unethical fashion is that based on Greed
what is that based on
the same reason Sam did it is a one-part
greed one-part enthusiasm go fast and
break things one part lack of adult
supervision
right uh what you what
what you could say is that
that
um you know the The Regulators ought to
just be very very clear if you were very
clear you'd say look
you've got like 180 days in order to
register your token with the SEC and you
register and give us all fill out these
forms give us all these facts answer our
questions and we'll tell you whether
you're a currency whether or not you're
a commodity whether or not your security
and whether or not you're allowed to
trade and at the end of the 180 days if
you haven't actually registered you're
shut down and nobody can buy and sell
and trade this thing anywhere in the
world and that that would actually clean
up the industry in a hurry or your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
foreign